[Música]
y
llama mucho la atención los hechos
recientes que han tenido lugar en eeuu
teniendo en cuenta el ambiente electoral
que hay de cara a las elecciones de
medio término que están previstas para
final de año para el mes de noviembre
sobre todo los hechos que han rodeado al
partido republicano es decir los líos
del ex presidente de donald trump y la
justicia por la insurrección en el
capitolio el 6 de enero sus reclamos sin
fundamentos sólidos para reclamar por
los resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales
también la apropiación de documentos que
se llevó a la residencia de mal halago
que su residencia campestre en el estado
de florida que fue recientemente
inspeccionada por el fbi tema del que
también vamos a hablar las diferencias
de opiniones también al interior de este
partido lo que presenta a ésta como una
formación política que está buscando tal
vez un nuevo rumbo puede ser un rumbo un
poco más radical un poco más hacia el
populismo que es lo que está buscando el
partido republicano eso también lo vamos
a analizar en este programa lo cierto es
que son estos hechos recientes han
provocado un aumento digamos en ese
fanatismo en ese extremo de los
seguidores más fieles los más cercanos
del expresidente de trump han mostrado
sus firmes convicciones de mantenerse
del lado del expresidente pero también
han aumentado las disputas internas en
el partido también lo vamos a analizar
lo cierto es que diferencias de
perspectivas entre sus filas hacia el
rumbo que debe tomar esta formación
política de otro lado está el partido
demócrata haciendo muchos intentos casi
desesperados para no ceder terreno en
esas elecciones de medio término hoy en
el debate de france 24 vamos a analizar
la situación política de eeuu cómo está
el panorama en este país estos hechos
recientes que como decía están muy
cercanos al ex presidente de donald
trump y a su formación política el
partido republicano para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a yale núñez es ya
es estratega conservadora e integrante
de independent women forum y adhesiva es
que ya se estratega demócrata y ex
presidenta estatal de la florida por el
partido demócrata les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram en facebook donde no se
encuentran como france24 y un bajo s
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24 en
youtube también ustedes pueden seguir
nuestra señal en streaming y dejar sus
comentarios a través del chat en vivo
aprovecho para saludar también a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de el debate que ya están disponibles en
el podcast en spotify deezer y tienen
comienza entonces con jolie dándole la
bienvenida al programa gracias por
acompañarnos el día de hoy ya lee punto
de partida sobre las impresiones que hay
sobre estos hechos recientes de los
últimos días de esta última semana en
eeuu el allanamiento a la residencia de
mar a lago la declaración de allen vice
élder que también sobre este fraude
fiscal por parte de este funcionario que
trabajó en una de las empresas que están
relacionadas con el expresidente trump
las primarias en alaska en wyoming los
hechos recientes allí en la unión
americana
bueno definitivamente han sido tiempos
turbulentos por acá y la realidad en
estos momentos es que hay muchas
personas que se están preguntando cómo
un hecho como éste ha tomado lugar y me
refiero por supuesto al allanamiento del
presidente el allanamiento que se hizo a
mar a lago en su residencia de acabo de
florida del presidente de donald trump
el presidente el número 45 de los eeuu
esto como mencionó es algo que nunca
había tomado lugar en los eeuu no tenía
precedente que se allanará por parte de
las fuerzas del fbi la residencia
privada de un presidente especialmente
cuando no estaba ni siquiera presente el
presidente de donald trump en su
residencia creo que hay gran parte del
electorado que no está conforme con lo
que ha pasado que creen que esto es una
situación que hasta cierto punto se ha
politizado y que se ha llevado a un
extremo que no tendría que haber sido
llevada más allá de lo que pudiera haber
en cuanto material clasificado por su
parte el presidente de unalt oncca dijo
que gran parte de ese material ya estaba
desclasificado o que el material que él
tenía en su posesión estaba
desclasificado está por verse y yo soy
creo que la ley debe ser cumplida y que
nadie está por encima de la ley pero
definitivamente desde el comienzo de la
presidencia de donald trump ha habido un
ensañamiento profundo con todo lo que
respecta a él y vamos a ver qué es lo
que sucede en cuanto a esta orden de
allanamiento que ahora el juez
granger ha dicho que será revelaba al
público para que tengan acceso a ver de
qué realmente se trata yo creo que los
estadounidenses merecen claridad en
cuanto a lo que es el contenido de esta
orden para poder entender realmente y
tener la verdad de nuestro lado y saber
qué es lo que se estaba buscando en las
residencias de donaldson
la perspectiva de nuestra invitada de
hoy entonces el salud y también la
palabra adhesiva es estratega demócrata
y ex representante estatal de la florida
por el partido demócrata también
bienvenida a daisy gracias por estar con
nosotros punto de partida también
impresiones sobre lo que ha sucedido en
los últimos días allí en eeuu
prácticamente todo está girando en torno
a los dos partidos políticos al
ex-presidente trump y ya se está
comenzando a calentar este ambiente
electoral de cara a esas elecciones de
medio término previstas para final de
año
es ciertamente gracias por la invitación
lo que hemos estado viendo estas últimas
dos semanas ha sido una en un debate
político ardiente y mucho referente a la
situación con la el allanamiento de la
residencia al presidente ex presidente
de donald trump lo que nos indica que
esta nación es como siempre como este
como tiene su reputación una nación
vendió nadie está por encima de la ley
incluyendo ex presidente la información
es que se le dieron varios chances al ex
presidente de devolver los documentos
su abogado estuvo presente durante el
allanamiento él estuvo observando el
allanamiento por televisión cerrada y
estuvo eso fue notificado no fue una
sorpresa así que él se le dio varias
oportunidades se le hizo un supina para
que presentara los documentos no lo hizo
pero mientras tanto los republicanos
están con este debate hemos estamos
saliendo de dos semanas de de unas
victorias impresionantes por parte del
presidente actual joe biden
donde ha podido pasar y se ha
concentrado y sus paquetes legislativos
la ley de reducción de inflación a la
ley de chips varios paquetes económicos
al mismo tiempo la data de los del
desempleo indica que se crearon 528 mil
empleos en julio el desempleo está en el
3.5 un récord bajo de nude de
vacantes y se ha reducido enormemente el
número de personas aplicando por el
desempleo si también sabemos que el
costo de la gasolina que es un punto
carta caliente para los americanos a
continúa en declive y esta semana está
por debajo de los 4 dólares más o menos
un averaje 3.5 así que el presidente de
iovine se puede al ataca a cachar varias
victorias muchas victorias en las
últimas dos semanas bueno cómo ven
ustedes el resumen de la semana
involucra muchísimos temas voy a tratar
de abarcar lo la mayoría de temas que
sea posible quiero comenzar por esa
controversia que hay en la sociedad
estadounidense y también a nivel
político por la divulgación de los
motivos de esta redada la fiscalía y en
eeuu
han
visto muchísima presión en torno a ellos
para que divulguen cuáles fueron los
motivos de esta redada en la residencia
de mara lago daisy y muchos dicen que es
necesario dar a conocer estos motivos
usted cree que esto se calmaría un poco
los ánimos o esto aquí se está yendo un
poco más allá de lo que la justicia
permite simplemente por darle un poco de
contentillo al expresidente de trump que
ha aprovechado esta oportunidad para
convocar medios y convocar también a sus
seguidores para decir que pues la
fiscalía tenía otros puntos de vista o
bueno ha discrepado en torno a los
motivos para llevar a cabo esta redada
hay otros que están completamente a
favor de los puntos de vista que ha
expresado la justicia estadounidense
lo que hemos visto es que inmediatamente
después del suceso al precedente demandó
que se publicaran todos los documentos
relacionados con esta redada la fiscalía
inmediatamente dio ok lo vamos a hacer
pero esto en los eeuu todo esto tiene un
proceso el proceso indica que tiene que
donde un juez que tiene que
desclasificar digamos esa información y
han estado en esta en eso en esas
conversaciones en los últimos días hoy
un juez le dijo a la fiscalía que
volvieran a presentar un documento con
ciertas redacciones porque hay cosas que
hay que proteger por ejemplo el nombre
de los informantes y cosas clasificadas
y que se la lleven de regreso para él
para entonces darle permiso para que
publiquen esa esa parte de la espina de
los documentos lo que sí sabemos es que
los abogados del señor trump en este
healing que hubo ultimadamente se
mantuvieron bastante callados y no
hicieron ningún no levantaron ninguna
digamos ninguna querella en ninguna
queja
y lo que hemos visto es que están
relativamente digamos asustados porque
no se sabe exactamente qué hay qué
información está en ese documento o sea
puede ser una arma de doble filo para él
que le favorezca pero también tenga
información que sea muy dañina para él
claro ya lee su opinión al respecto
sobre esta posible divulgación de los
motivos de esta redada es necesario
darlos a conocer es necesario por la
salud de la justicia estadounidense y
también de la democracia estadounidense
hoy simplemente una exigencia del
presidente
del ex presidente por todo este caso
bueno yo creo que el presidente
no da puntada sin dedal yo creo que se
está pidiendo que se revele en estos
documentos porque saber perfectamente
que no hay nada en ello que lo pueda
incriminar él ha mantenido su inocencia
a través de los comentarios que ha hecho
y él insiste que estos documentos han
estado clasificados él insiste que fue
injustificada e injusta está
este allanamiento que se hizo a la
residencia de mar al lago en lakua él
dijo que no estaba presente
es un hecho sin precedentes en los eeuu
es un hecho que en la base conservadora
no ha caído bien no ha sentado bien
porque piensan que se está politizando
una situación y creo que están
despertando también un sentimiento que
está vaya tranquilo o dormido en cuanto
a lo que es este conflicto tan tan
fuerte interno que se ha creado de
división dentro del país y continúan
buscando motivos continúan buscando
cosas donde quizás no las hay y no digo
que en esta situación en específico no
haya nada pero continuamente vemos el
deseo de división por parte del partido
demócrata vemos el interés de poner a un
lado y dividir a una parte de la nación
y yo no creo que eso está correcto yo
creo que este es el momento si ellos
realmente quieren unificar a la nación
como dijo bardem en su lema de campaña
presidencial y sanar a la nación esta no
es la manera de hacer las cosas estamos
en un momento serio dentro de los eeuu
con una economía sumamente frágil en el
medio de una
donde un paquete de huevos en el mercado
ha subido un 35% un poco de leche un 15%
donde las madres no tienen fórmula para
alimentar a sus bebés estamos en una
situación bastante seria económicamente
hablando donde el
sector inmobiliario ha disminuido en
cuanto a sus cuentas donde la reserva
federal continúa subiendo las tasas de
interés de una manera descontrolada y
que ya están diciendo que es
contraproducente antes de la próxima
reunión que van a tener en septiembre
entonces este no es el momento de
politizar ningún dicho este es el
momento de unificar a la nación este es
el momento de cumplir lo que ellos
dijeron y no han cumplido es el momento
de erradicar la crisis tan fuerte que
tenemos en nuestras fronteras en estos
momentos hay encuestas que demuestran
que hay personas que creen que esto es
una invasión lo que está ocurriendo en
la frontera sur y líderes demócratas
inclusive es en nueva york y en decir lo
has rentado que están sufriendo el
efecto de esto entonces por qué hacer
esto por qué buscar la desunión
busquemos unificar a los eeuu
mundial y éste menciona un punto
importante y es un término importante es
lo que uno ve fuera de las fronteras de
estados unidos estando ajeno a la
realidad
de este país en el día a día en medio de
éste
tratando de levantar la economía del
país y de salir adelante después de los
confinamientos que dejó en la pandemia
de kobe 19 lo que uno nota acá es que
hay por parte de los dos partidos de
ambos lados políticos un intento de
división y desprestigiando las
instituciones haciendo pequeñas grietas
en la democracia eeuu generando
interrogantes sobre en puntos
importantes como por ejemplo las
elecciones presidenciales o la forma en
que procede la justicia o generando
dudas en la forma de cómo procede el fbi
y también desacreditando constantemente
al opositor político esto está generando
problemas para garantizar la fortaleza
de la democracia estadounidense que
piensa usted yo pienso que generalmente
cuando vemos división por supuesto que
se genera el descontento en la población
y por supuesto que eso se refleja a la
hora
de ir a las urnas de votar es por eso
que es tan importante ejercer dentro de
los eeuu el privilegio del voto y
hacerlo de una manera inteligente elegir
a políticos que realmente trabajen por
la nación no solamente que vayan y
hablen en las campañas y que pidan ayuda
de los que generalmente tienen menos
cuando cuando es tiempo de donar a las
campañas sino que ayuden a ese sector de
la población que hagan algo por con los
más necesitados del país y en estos
momentos en estos momentos el liderazgo
que tenemos lamentablemente no ha hecho
esto estábamos hablando previamente
en su otra invitada mencionaba sobre el
plan de reducción el acto de reducción
de inflación realmente va a ayudar esto
a la inflación cuando vemos que más bien
está dirigiendo sus fondos a lo que es
cuidar el cambio o hacer ciertas cambios
sobre lo del cambio climático y no vemos
que hayan dirigido dinero a erradicar el
problema que tenemos por ejemplo con
inmigración en estos momentos dentro de
los eeuu es un problema porque está
entrando 30.000 están entrando drogas
por la frontera está esto causando
gastos al gobierno federal en cuanto a
la cantidad de dinero que se destina en
cuanto a las personas que van llegando
al país entonces si no buscamos si no
buscamos métodos efectivos para poder
lidiar con la crisis interna que tenemos
en estos momentos en los eeuu poco vamos
a poder hacer por nuestros aliados en el
exterior tampoco vamos a poder hacer en
un futuro por la verdadera democracia de
este país que es la que todos añoramos
veis y también destacado a lo largo de
esta semana de los últimos días en cerca
de
66 mil migrantes que llegaron a eeuu a
través de la frontera sur a través de la
frontera común entre texas y la
república mexicana fueron enviados en
buses a otros estados principalmente al
estado de nueva york esto como una
política del estado de texas que está en
manos republicanas de enviarlo a estados
que están en manos demócratas para que
ellos se hagan estos migrantes porque a
ellos no les interesa tenerlos allí qué
opina usted de esta política que se
puede decir y qué y porque washington no
toma otro tipo de medidas a nivel
federal que permita un mejor manejo de
los migrantes que están entrando al país
ciertamente el que catalogamos esto como
un juego político de los de los estados
sobre todo texas que usa esto como una
táctica para sencillamente crear teatro
político y no resolver las cosas lo que
sabemos muy bien es que el presidente
joe biden se ha dedicado a legislar a
presentar paquetes que resuelven los
problemas de la clase media americana de
la clase trabajadora americana lo que va
a mejorar la economía en general porque
las personas se preocupan más de cómo
van a ganar el pan de cómo van a
mantener a sus familias de cómo a
comprar las cosas y estos paquetes
legislativos los van a ayudar a eso
reduciendo el costo de las medicinas el
costo de acceso a la salud
en fin de
asegurarse que las compañías grandes
multimillonarias paguen los los recursos
los taxes los dineros que tienen que
pagar al gobierno para que estas de
veras que tengamos los recursos para
ayudar a las personas que lo necesitan y
los recursos para nuestra y mantener
nuestra infraestructura en nuestros
puentes carreteras edificios las cosas
que necesitan atención es también parte
de las leyes de infraestructura que pasó
el presidente lo que sí estamos viendo y
hablando de división es que todos estos
paquetes excepto por el
pack que tenía que ver con los
beneficios a los veteranos han pasado
sin ninguna cooperación sin ninguna
ayuda de los republicanos los
republicanos no quieren venir a la mesa
a negociar no quieren venir a la mesa a
discutir no han presentado ellos ningún
paquete político ningún paquete
legislativo para que yo diga ok no nos
gusta tula lo que está presentando vamos
a considerar esto no lo hacen lo único
que hacen es decir no
no no no a todo y sencillamente no votan
por nada que avanza el presidente
entonces ellos son también los que
continúan por medio de la actitud del
presidente de decir institucionalizar
las cosas que siempre han sido normales
en este en este país por ejemplo en las
elecciones resulta que esté presente
todavía hasta el día de hoy no acepta
que perdió las elecciones entonces sigue
motivando y creando 6 años con sus
seguidores diciendo que les robaron las
elecciones porque no acepta como han
aceptado todos los presidentes a lo
largo de todas las
de los siglos que tiene esta nación y
aceptan los resultados y hay una
transición de poder
normal una transición que es esperada
cada vez que se gana o se pierde que
sucede una elección entonces
hablando de crear división el presidente
del ex presidente de donald trump es el
master de crear división en este país ya
lee el máster creando división en este
discurso se viene presentando desde qué
donald trump pues decidió no aceptar
estos resultados y dijo que hubo fraude
principalmente en algunos conteos de
votos en el estado de georgia sin
embargo a pesar de todas estas críticas
de estos procesos legales que se están
enfrentando y los hechos recientes el ex
presidente sigue cosechando
muchísimo favoritismo
entre sus votantes republicanos pero
también ha ganado algunos adeptos en
nuevos a qué se debe esa popularidad del
expresidente trump pese a estos casos
que uno pensaría que le juegan en contra
de su imagen
bueno yo creo que hay parte del
electorado que quedó muy disgustado
después de las elecciones yo creo que
eso es más que evidente los hechos y la
historia lo ha demostrado yo siempre
creo en una transición pacífica creo que
esto es una república democrática y que
debemos respetar nuestro proceso
electoral y si queremos cambiar a los
líderes que tenemos a hacerlo a través
del poder del voto ahora en este país
tenemos la primera enmienda una enmienda
que nos permite hablar y expresarnos
libremente sobre nuestros pareceres
políticos nuestros pareceres en cuanto a
la religión etcétera tenemos libertad de
expresión si hay cierto grupo que no
cree que la elección se llevó a cabo de
una manera legítima ellos tienen su
derecho a expresarse
debido a la constitución que los protege
ahora lo que nadie tiene derecho es a
irrumpir a destruir propiedad etcétera
eso no es justificable pero si el
presidente de trump si un cierto grupo
del electorado no cree que la elección
fue legítima ellos tienen su derecho
bajo la ley de expresar su pensamiento y
la manera en que consideran que las
cosas pasó y eso debe ser respetado por
otra parte yo no cuestiono la
legitimidad del presidente bailén lo que
sí cuestiono es la situación en la que
se encuentra el pueblo estadounidense
del pueblo estadounidense continúa
enfrentando una crisis sumamente
profunda y es por eso que muchas
personas están cruzando a las filas del
partido republicano es por eso que
muchas personas no apoyan al presidente
baile incluyendo miembros de su propio
partido que no quieren ser asociados
políticamente con él cuando les piden
que en entrevistas de prensa y les dicen
por favor quiero usted le endosen en el
patrocinio del presidente de bailén y
dicen yo estoy corriendo esta campaña y
yo soy el que estoy postulando
siguiente baile y no quieren una
asociación directa con el presidente
porque saben el descontento que hay
entre el pueblo estadounidense con
respecto a la manera en que bailan
apoyar a a
se ha proyectado básicamente y ha
llevado a cabo la política del país
sabemos también perfectamente que este
plan de reducción de inflación en el
contactaron 750 billones de dólares o
sea 750 mil millones de dólares y lo
queremos decir correctamente si no no
está no está directamente atendiendo las
mayores necesidades de los
estadounidenses sabemos puede
incrementar los taxes de muchos
estadounidenses y eso no es lo que
quiere el pueblo tal y
según entiendo lo que usted dice hay
como una cierta desilusión por parte de
los ciudadanos estadounidenses frente a
las magistradas jon bites
correcto correcto porque la realidad es
que cuando uno va al mercado cuando va a
echar gasolina no quiero oír la excusa
de que putin y la guerra en rusia son
las que están causando estos gastos
quiere ver el liderazgo de un presidente
que se encargue de su pueblo que tome
medidas que beneficien al pueblo y eso
lamentablemente no lo hemos estado
viendo por parte de esta administración
yo creo que a todos los estadounidenses
les gustaría ver progreso y fuera bajo
el presidente que fuera el
estadounidense lo que quiere es progreso
y prosperidad para este país y para esta
gran nación y no lo hemos estado viendo
con el presidente y cuál es su opinión
hay una cierta desilusión por parte de
ese electorado que apostó por las ideas
y por lo que proponía el presidente
debaten hay que decir que la coyuntura
internacional es compleja no solamente
para el presidente baiden sino para la
mayoría de países del mundo que también
están tratando de poner en marcha sus
economías después de el punto álgido de
la pandemia de kobe 19 aún así
eeuu pues es un país con una economía en
ventaja si la comparamos con muchos
países del mundo pero usted percibe una
cierta desilusión un cierto
distanciamiento o un enfriamiento en esa
luna de miel que hubo entre el
electorado y el presidente va a tener en
el inicio del mandato
típicamente en los ciclos electorales
ciclos de presidente hay altas y bajas y
ciertamente el presidente estuvo
lidiando con un periodo de digamos de
incertidumbre porque estaban subiendo
los precios de la gasolina no se habían
pasado ninguno de los paquetes
legislativos
continuaba la división pero lo que
estamos viendo es dos semanas que
tenemos de increíbles
victorias para el presidente de paquetes
legislativos que toman tiempo
implementar pero que estamos muy seguros
que van a tener resultados de hecho ya
estamos viendo el precio de la gasolina
bajando vertiginosamente la en creación
sin precedentes de nuevos empleos más de
medio millón del mes de julio el
desempleo la cifra de desempleo va súper
bajas
así que si estamos viendo progresos y
estamos viendo y la gente lo está
sintiendo la gente se va a va a ver los
resultados de esto esta inclusión de
como dijo nuestra colega de dinero
va directamente a lo que es la clase
media clase trabajadora la clase de
personas que están sufriendo que habían
estado sufriendo de esta de la alta de
la gasolina pero ya estamos en camino a
la recuperación no estamos con los ojos
blindados sabemos que hubo un periodo
difícil pero estamos muy seguros que
estamos en vías de recuperación daisy y
volteamos para ver la otra cara de la
moneda y es el partido republicano
leyendo análisis y
comentarios para preparar este tema veía
muchos analistas internacionales que
hablan de divisiones dentro del partido
republicano que tan notorio es esa
percepción si existe esa percepción
usted que piensa al respecto de eso
bueno la realidad es que el partido
republicano se ha conocido como el
partido conservador un partido del
gobierno de limitado un partido que
creía en lo en orden ley orden pero lo
que estamos viendo es todo lo contrario
un partido que ahora es dominado por la
maga m
digamos la secuencia del presidente de
donald trump es un partido donde todo es
que es mas divisorio un partido que está
liderado por un presidente que está bajo
muy investigaciones múltiples lo ha
estado siempre y donde es precisamente
hace unos días el presidente de su
compañía fiscal fue
encausado por la ley y si le añadimos
los nombres de michael flynn pomar por
rogers ton steven van casi todas las
personas que te están rodeando el
presidente todas han sido acusadas y
convictas de crímenes es un par
prácticamente una asociación de
malhechores y esto deja un mal sabor en
la gente sobre qué es lo que está
pasando con el partido qué es lo que
está pasando con este presidente que
todos acaban con cargos criminales así
que esto es la conversación que se está
teniendo sobre el partido republicano
dalí y su opinión sobre esta posible
ruptura o estas discrepancias al
interior del partido republicano hay
quienes no ven con buenos ojos
todos estos entramados judiciales que
están rodeando al ex presidente de
donald trump sobre todo si él quiere
aspirar a ser nuevamente elegido como
presidente y también aprovecho para unir
ahí algunos comentarios de liz cheney
que ella misma dijo que el partido
republicano estaba muy enferma y le
costaría mucho
curarlo hay que recordar que ella se
presentó en las primarias de wyoming
este esta semana y perdió precisamente
eso evidencia un poco esas esas dos
visiones distintas que hay del partido o
como lo vio usted mira es anclado yo soy
parte del forma internacional
independiente del foro independiente de
mujeres de washington y sí y lo que te
puedo decir es que cuando veo lo que ha
pasado con visión y ha sido básicamente
la posición que ha tomado nosotros en el
foro independiente de mujeres siempre
abogamos por políticas que hagan crecer
a las mujeres de nuestro país en todos
los aspectos y todos los sectores de la
sociedad especialmente por ejemplo yo yo
creo que es importante que las mujeres
corran en cargos políticos y para hacer
la diferencia y vemos que una de las
candidatas que corrió recientemente con
otra visión y fue apoyada por el
presidente del show y obtuvo un triunfo
y cuando vemos las entrevistas que han
hecho en wyoming al respecto es porque
simplemente no creen que eligió ni se
dio lo que son las normativas y las
políticas del partido republicano o sea
que no cree en lo que es la base y el
fundamento de lo que se basa el partido
republicano a través de este papel que
ha desempeñado en el de enero 6 en el
cual solamente estaba ella y otros otros
congresistas republicanos que he
escogido como como los republicanos
representando al partido republicano
dentro de este comité sin embargo los y
los integrantes que hubiera podido
escoger el partido republicano para ese
comité fueron ignorados entonces
realmente es un comité
neutral no es un comité parcializado yo
creo que esa es una pregunta válida que
tenemos que hacernos como como
como contribuyentes o como ex
espectadores de lo que es este proceso
investigativo que se está llevando a
cabo con los eventos tan lamentables que
ocurrieron en enero 6 en el capitolio yo
estaba en washington dc y te puedo decir
que fue un día realmente oscuro y yo
vivía tan solo unas cuadras del
capitolio fue un día realmente oscuro en
la historia de los eeuu ahora lo que no
creo que es correcto es establecer un
comité que esté parcializado y no le
lleve a los estadounidenses la verdad y
una opinión neutral y no parcializada de
los hechos y de las investigaciones que
se están llevando a cabo luisín y dijo
que dejaba de hacer actos de campaña
precisamente para estas primarias allí
en wyoming debido a amenazas de muerte
que recibió de los trompistas no
solamente ahora sino desde que
precisamente tomó una postura un poco
más crítica frente a la situación de la
insurrección del 6 de enero allí en el
capitolio y esa votación que hubo en la
que otros días congresistas republicanos
votaron pues también en contra de
el entonces presidente
es esto normal en estados unidos en el
país cuna de la democracia en américa
ver usted a seguidores trompistas
amenazado de muerte a una política
simplemente porque discrepa con algunas
de las ideas de un partido político
nunca la violencia de la respuesta a
ningún tipo de amenaza que se le lance a
un congresista republicano o demócrata o
independiente o de cualquier tipo de
partido está justificada creo que es la
posición errada yo no creo en este tipo
de actitudes violentas no las respaldo
en lo absoluto y creo que está mal por
otra parte yo creo que estos eventos
debieron haber sido discutidos de una
manera como le digo que hubiera una
neutralidad y no una parcialización y en
cuanto a la manera en que se
desarrollaron los hechos sabemos
perfectamente que estos son hechos que
tienen que ser investigados de manera
seria de manera directa y que todo el
peso de la ley tiene que caer sobre las
personas que ejercieron violencia en ese
en el ataque al capitolio en enero seis
murieron oficiales
de la ley que deben ser respetados y que
deberían y que estaban ahí simplemente
cumpliendo con su deber claro pero más
allá más allá de esto necesitábamos los
estadounidenses un comité que no
estuviera parcializado y que hablará con
la verdad sobre las investigaciones que
estaban tomando lugar para investigar
estos hechos
visitábamos y también vamos llegando al
final del programa el último bloque
antes de las conclusiones quería
preguntarle a daisy si todo este
entramado judicial que uno puede
entender muy por encima lo que está de
verdad allí
investigándose y en juego no tenemos
suficiente tiempo como para profundizar
en todos los temas pero cree usted
firmemente que donald trump va a llegar
a estas elecciones para buscar esa es el
segundo periodo presidencial va a llegar
otra vez a la casa blanca
bueno de que va a intentar es posible y
este es donald trump el cuando se decide
hacer algo lo hace no de que gane es
otra cosa pero lo que estamos viendo es
que es una persona que ha creado una
tremenda división en este país cualquier
éxito los hechos de enero 6 diciéndole a
su as en su real ya su gente vámonos
para el capitolio esto no vamos a
aceptar esto
y pasando horas sin fin de decir esto no
está bien ver y no darle órdenes claras
contundentes a las personas a los a los
miembros policiales para que
actuaran ya en contra de esa desde esa
de esa turba violenta que entró en el
capitolio lo que sí estamos viendo es un
comité que ha estado serio que ha estado
investigando que ha estado reuniéndose
con diferentes personas y estamos viendo
las agencias policiales del fbi y todo
eso
encontrando las personas que fueron
ya más de 800 casos y esos casos se han
ido resolviendo poco a poco y estas
personas la mayoría han recibido cargos
de cárcel
si eso es eso da a conocer que este es
un país de leyes
de producción es decir que hemos perdido
la conexión con charly vamos a tratar de
retomar lo antes posible para hacer las
conclusiones para el cierre del programa
mientras tanto sigo con ustedes y
hagamos entonces las conclusiones
mientras damos tiempo para conectar
nuevamente a yale para que nos cuente su
conclusión final para el cierre del
programa que sigue entonces que vamos a
ver en las próximas semanas siempre lo
digo ya es frase habitual acá en el
programa no hay bola de cristal para
saber lo que viene el futuro político
pero en este caso en eeuu que podemos
ver podemos ver al presidente de trump
tanto un testimonio bajo juramento por
lo menos en nueva york para responder
por por estos
estos casos de fiscales allí en el
estado de nueva york en la ciudad de
nueva york como lo ve usted
bueno el presidente que como siempre ha
hecho él le dice que sí que va a
participar para la última hora se echa
para atrás dice que no no tiene razón
para testificar no tienes razón para
participar en esos procesos judiciales
estamos en proceso de primarias en los
eeuu y ahora vamos a mira de las
elecciones en noviembre elecciones y
bicamerales que pasan los años
alternativos que hay presidencias
elecciones generales y lo que vamos a
ver es que va los resultados van a
indicar cómo están las personas pensando
en las primarias son entre las personas
de su mismo partido entonces esos son
escogidos por las bases y si
generalmente estas son las bases
militantes del partido pasa ambos en los
republicanos como los demócratas por eso
los candidatos deben hacer más o de
derecha o de izquierda y lo que vamos a
ver es que si tengo que finalizar el
programa le agradezco está la gran
conclusión de cierre ya le dejó el
programa porque ya tenía que ir a hacer
precisamente la grabación de su programa
de radio también debía ir en vivo
entonces tuvo que desconectarse nos
quedamos pendientes de su conclusión
final pero ustedes muchísimas gracias
por la sintonía daisy también gracias
por haber hecho esta conclusión de
cierre del programa que ustedes pueden
seguir dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan en sintonía de france 24
[Música]